a New Jersey family is suing local and
state agencies in South Carolina for how
they treated their mentally ill son Paul
taschek jr. was battling skits of
schizoaffective disorder he was killed
while walking along in South Carolina
interstate last year just after he had
been picked up and released by police
and paramedics in an interview you'll
only see on CBS news Jim Axelrod sat
down with two sharks family Jim good
morning it sounds like this young man
needed some help
good morning Michele he certainly did
Paul Terre shucks family has filed a
civil lawsuit against more than a dozen
defendants including law enforcement and
paramedics now among the items of
evidence in the case is body camera
video a warning some of what you're
about to see is graphic it's been a year
of crippling emotion for Cindy and Paul
terrashock a year since the death of
their 26 year old son also named Paul
it's still not easy to talk about is it
no it's talking about him gets me really
upset talking about this stuff it gets
me angry
Paul Tyra shaked schizoaffective
disorder suffering delusions and
hallucinations but he was getting on
with his life until one night last
September when he had a psychotic
breakdown traveling along this highway
near Orangeburg South Carolina
parked for a roadside break a trucker
suddenly saw terrashock walking toward
him naked man
fix me I take off as the trucker drove
down the interstate
he realized Tara shuck was riding on his
rig and called 9-1-1 officers from three
different law enforcement agencies
responded including Orangeburg County
sheriff's deputy Clifford Doral ski
oh he's under the influence nobody can
see that who was certain Tara shuck was
high or drunk
Duras keys body camera recorded what
happened when EMS arrived
Tara shucks didn't answer the first
responders who were berating and cursing
at him so they shoved an ammonia capsule
up his nose he didn't flinch at that
point someone should have stepped up and
says we got to take him in someplace
he's not just someone to to let go do
you want to go to the hospital
yes or no
do you want to go to jail come on I'm
gonna give you a ride you're not going
to jail you're not under arrest I'm
gonna give you a ride give you a ride
through the safe environment that's all
I want I want to make sure you are all
right the deputy puts terrashock into
his cruiser drives him 15 miles to this
gas station near the county line a gas
station that was closed at the time this
is the last time Paul terrashock is seen
alive it's just watching you walk to the
step he was escorted by you know it's
death I think I just hit a person on the
interstate nearly five hours later the
same EMS crew was called to deal with
terrashock again back on the same
highway this time he was dead a
toxicology report from the Orangeburg
County coroner's office came up clean no
drugs no alcohol
despite this deputy Clifford arouse key
is still on the job at the Orangeburg
County Sheriff's Department and so is
one of the EMTs they didn't do their job
that's it they just didn't do their job
they didn't care enough about human life
to do their job we asked both the
Orangeburg County Sheriff's Department
and the EMS Department for on-camera
interviews they both declined citing an
ongoing investigation South Carolina's
statewide investigative law enforcement
agency is examining whether there was
criminal conduct by the first responders
I can't imagine what it must be like for
that family to watch that footage I mean
it's just heartbreaking that's why they
filed the suit in addition to wanting
some kind of accountability and justice
they're looking for some sort of
monetary damage that will get the
attention of legislators in South
Carolina to implement some new laws it's
a tough job being an EMS will no doubt
about it but when you think about you
know some of the rules and procedures
again it's just like in policing and
let's be clear about this there are
people in that community that are as
outraged of Professor we spoke to it the
University of Nevada Las Vegas who
teaches this stuff says this video is
training for every EMS worker
in what not to do of course the majority
of EMS workers are people we need and
get themselves in wonderful ways they
know to ask is drugs and are drugs
involved is alcohol involved why not ask
also is there a mental health problem
wouldn't you have been able to handstand
their operating plan you should
recognize those should but instead of
driving them to a gas station they maybe
should have driven them to a hospital
all right Jim thank you